kimberly and i when we split up
we we stay i i
i credited a thing i call living life at
ninety percent on my book positively
unstoppable the first chapter is living
life at ninety percent it's
it's based on the formula life is ten
percent of what happens to you and
ninety percent of how you react to love
that man and and not just the way i live
my life and
when we got done and we both knew like
we were growing apart she needed someone
who's more active
and i needed to focus on the business
because it wasn't going anywhere i made
all this money in wrestling but i was
putting it all back in putting it all on
black on you know gdp yoga
and uh
i knew that she as we we were so we kind
of raised each other even though she was
20 and i was 34 we kind of raised each
other coming up
and i loved her so much as a human being
and it was like
she also did this too because she's the
one who wanted to leave
she
[Music]
i said if you take half
we're done
you didn't earn this i did everything i
broke my body up everything
if you friggin take what i give you
i'll always be there for you and which
was about 25 percent of our net worth
okay
and i did it for a reason
we we did this is all in the first four
months of splitting up right we didn't
get divorced until years later okay but
we split up and out that was it as far
as i was concerned
and when we got in front of the uh the
mediation attorney
i said to him i said can you do me a
favor i said give me five minutes
and i said
when he left i said kim i said i just
wanted to see if you'd do it
i said now that you've proven yourself
that what we had was so much more than
just
a marriage and a relationship
etc
i said i'm going to give you half
everything get out of here you were
testing her the entire time just to see
what she would do 100
and she passed the test you know what
she said what
nope
a deal's a deal
wow dude and i said
what are you talking about i'm telling
you i'm gonna give you a half
and she said no
a deal's a deal do you promise to be
there if i need you i said i'd do that
anyway wow man so that's the
relationships now you understand
her husband i love him like a brother
now i mean like super super tight now
because that was 17 years ago dude you
could write a book on just how to get
from like out of a relationship the
right way and and
have it be
actually a beneficial relationship in
current and in the future and like you
hear so many stories about these ugly
ridiculous hollywood breakups everything
in the news right now with johnny depp
and amber hurd and will smith
potentially
and here you are telling your wife hey
look
i'll give you 25 you didn't earn all
this and then on the last second you
flip it and say i'm actually going to
give you a half and she says no i'm good
i just want you to be there for me
what explain the blueprint for that
you know it's just like
i wise
when we would go through the crazy
yelling screaming that everybody goes
through
i could pull myself down and go the only
thing
that's important
is our friendship
and what will you make
because i kind of raised myself growing
up as a kid you know i've been pretty
good at
parenting myself
and i've done some really stupid [ __ ] so
i don't think it's like always been good
join the club
yeah exactly you know so the bottom line
is is that
anyone who's in a relationship with me
if they didn't get along with kim
that's like that's like my sister wow at
this point you know what i mean like no
you don't get along with my sister
you're not for me
[Music]